buonasera buonasera a tutti credo che
poche cose siano meravigliosamente
brutte come come il lavoro per parlare
di lavoro voglio partire proprio dall
inizio dio creò in sette giorni creò
tutto creò le stelle i fiori i cieli
pesci gli animali adamo ed eva e li mise
nel paradiso a non fare niente a vivere
in contemplazione massima del di se
stessi e di questo creato è di lui e ma
loro disobbedì rono curiosoni preso il
frutto dell'albero della conoscenza
erano curiosi volevano conoscere e lui
qui insomma sia rabbiosi arabo tanto e
li condannò a lavorare dice
letteralmente alla bibbia c'è il lavoro
nasce quando l'uomo e la donna vengono
cacciati dalla tua razzi di estrema
destra e quindi il lavoro è una condanna
non sta nei primi sette giorni viene
dopo e nasce come una punizione e questo
idea di di lavoro come punizione è
un'idea che ci portiamo ancora dentro
stamattina l'autista che mi portava da
salerno col pulmino vi parlavo del mio
intervento mi ha detto ma il lavoro se
ti piace non è lavoro quindi l'idea che
quando non ti piace è lavoro e dunque
punizione se abbiamo ancora dentro
in fondo ai miei forse anche i vostri
nonni o bisnonni che all 89 anni
lavoravano nei campi oppure lasciavano
l'italia qui piroscafi o facevano o
lavoravano in miniera magari
e la domanda ti piace il tuo lavoro non
dava nessun significato cia come mi
piace il mio lavoro io io devo lavorare
se no non vivono non mangia e non
sopravvivo e interessante una
definizione di lavoro e la questa è la
prima definizione della lingua inglese
il lavoro è definito come sforzo fisico
volto al soddisfacimento di bisogni
materiali di una comunità arriviamo in
italia oggi probabilmente non più del 23
per cento della popolazione associa al
proprio lavoro la parola sforzo fisico
non che non ci sforziamo è ma non e'piu
sforzo fisico le macchine la civiltà
post industriale i servizi hanno
superato quel concetto soddisfacimento
dei bisogni materiali anche qui possiamo
discutere perché in fondo
parlo dell'italia un piatto di minestra
alla caritas e lo trovi sempre
probabilmente nella piramide dei bisogni
non si lavora più per sopravvivere in
senso stretto altrimenti si muore di
fame almeno non nel primo mondo si
lavora per per avere un ruolo nella
società per dar valore al proprio tempo
per avere delle soddisfazioni per
passione per inseguire un sogno
e poi anche interessante il lavoro erano
un soddisfacimento di bisogni di una
comunità
oggi ci lavora per se stessi al massimo
per la propria famiglia per chi ce l'ha
l'idea della comunità voleva dire ad
esempio se in villa di un paese della
provincia di potenza c'era un ciabattino
non apriva un secondo perché ce n'era
già uno il successo e perché poi c'era
un ciabattino un macellaio 4 agricoltori
7 che facevano altro e probabilmente
anche la merce di scambio era la valuta
corrente di il lavoro era una valuta
corrente no questa questo concetto è
evidentemente cambiato perché in fondo
sono cambiati i nostri bisogni
il lavoro
ci rende adulti ci rende liberi intorno
a quest idea che il lavoro ci rende
liberi
molti hanno fatto anche unico un'ironia
cinica terribile assegnandolo assegnando
al gol di schiavitù questo e come tutti
i campi di concentramento era un luogo
di schiavitù in cui venivano presi in
giro in qualche modo i deportati
dicendogli che il lavoro rende liberi di
qui non uscirai mai più e questa non è
passato è questo questo mondo ora voi
non potete leggere i numeri ve lo dico
io
esiste un indice si chiama global
slavery index nel 2016 sono calcolati 45
milioni di persone in stato di schiavitù
nel mondo stato di schiavitù e non
lavoro sottopagato lavoro nero stato di
schiavitù la schiavitù è una condizione
in cui non godi di nessun diritto di
libertà diritto di politico non ne
parliamo a di accesso alla sanità di
fatto sei un corpo che può avere tre
destinazioni lavora a oltranza traffici
sessuali mercante il traffico di organi
ecco se nei serbatoi per queste tre cose
rischia di to sono numeri base mondiale
e di stimato in 45 milioni a quel
livello ecco per dirvi che non sto
parlando di cose che non sono così
lontane
il quindi questa necessità di uscire
dallo stato di schiavitù di sentirci
qualcosa è quello che ci spinge ci
spinge probabilmente non più solo a
portare a casa la pagnotta a pagare il
mutuo ma anche a portare a casa delle
soddisfazioni e di qui nascono altre
alcuna altra parte delle beautiful abili
come direbbero gli organizzatori delle
cose brutte
per cui i contratti in nero le
dimissioni in bianco il fatto che ti
faccio lavorare ti faccio fare il lavoro
che ti piace ma vuole anche essere
pagato tutti i mesi ma no dai
mi sembra di esagerare no iniziano
richiedi un po troppo piuttosto la bomba
la bomba che i che esploderà nei
prossimi 10 15 anni di due o tre
generazioni che non hanno la pensione
non avranno la pensione
questo stalin stuckey e della cura delle
cose più abili più brutte di cui è
considerato talmente ineluttabile che se
ne parla fin poco ma è lì oggi non serve
hotel ma per dire che tra quindici anni
ci saranno milioni milioni di italiani
che non avranno la pensione o che
avranno pensioni indecenti e e tra
vent'anni ancora di più e tra 25 ancora
di più però è così sembra di parlare di
una cosa vera pioggia del terremoto c'è
da dire è ci sarà il terremoto e
moriremo in molti
cosa ci posso fare intorno a questi
concetti
min non vi voglio fare ridere ma mi è
venuto in mente un bellissimo film di
qualche anno fa a tutti di dustin
hoffman in cui lui per fare il suo
lavoro per fare il lavoro che gli piace
quello dell'attore si ritrova a fare
l'attrice per una vicenda carina si
ritrova a fare l'attrice e messo di
fronte a un amico che lo vede prepararsi
per andare a lavorare no dustin hoffman
è lì che si mette le calze coprenti la
parrucca gli occhialoni si rade sì
perché deve essere una donna perché poi
lavoro che adora l'amico lo guarda e gli
dice tu andrai all'inferno lui lo guarda
in risposta gli dice io non credo
nell'inferno
io credo nella disoccupazione
ecco che allora aveva venuto questa
questo scempio che non si chiude il
paradiso che ha come alternativa il
lavoro il lavoro che ha come contrario
la disoccupazione che sinonimo di
inferno e quindi questo non lavoro che
può essere allo stesso tempo l'inferno
o il paradiso cioè si rimane sospesi ma
su questo ci torno anche dopo e si
rimane sospeso cioè in fondo io credo
una generazione essere sospesi vuol dire
anche vivere un eterno presente per cui
faccio un lavoro che mi piace lo faccio
da precario e domani chi lo sa che un po
il ricatto che moltissime persone anche
presenti secondo me non li conosco
hanno tutti i giorni oppure ricatto del
per fare il lavoro che mi piace me ne
devo andare o altri ricatti simili ecco
uno dei uno dei miti più negative in
questo senso dell'ultimo periodo con
delle startup volevo dedicare un
angolino alle start up soprattutto start
up giovani che è un ossimoro start up
giovani è un ossimoro cioè non stanno
assieme la parola start up e la parola
giovani perché dire a un giovani visto
che non trovi lavoro fatti la tua
impresa ed e destinarlo a sperperare il
patrimonio familiare e gli strozzini
siano bene perché perché se non hai
sbagliato nella vita se non hai
esperienza
se non hai fatto errori non pagano
neanche fare impresa lo diceva la logica
si impara sugli errori
con tutto il rispetto ancora dei
presenti ma a 21 22 23 anni quanti
errori puoi avere fatto da cui imparare
a fare l'impresa però non c'è la
possibilità di imparare me ne rendo
conto il circolo vizioso che che poi
viene diciamo anche lì non mi giro a
cercare le motivazioni perché guardo
avanti lo guardo guardo a ai miti non
sono stessa prete che le start up che
hanno grande successo si chiamano
unicorni sono gli unicorni c i venture
capitalist i quelli che ci mettono i
soldi cercano gli unicorni sono quelli
dove tu metti mille euro oggi è un
milione tra cinque anni gli unicorni che
non so se avete idea di cosa siano
unicorno vi ricorre non esistono intanto
l'unicorno nasce così qualcuno
nel medioevo sull'atlantico trova questi
giorni bellissimi poi 4 ubriacone dice
di averlo visto sulla testa di un
cavallo bianco
evidentemente mentre la realtà è che di
questi corni vengono da un pesce
goffissimo è bruttissimo che si chiama
narvalo è una specie di pesce spada
venuto male praticamente è però c'è
rimasto solo il corno del narvalo e
quindi fraiche bellezza no quindi l'idea
di avere questa di creare una finta
bellezza che non esiste cioè come se ne
mentre un milione di anni un archeologo
marziano a terra su potenza di cui è
rimasto solo il ponte musmeci e dice ma
se questo punto è così bello ma che cosa
doveva essere la città attorno ecco
questo è il concetto di divi divine
dotate di ritorno di unicorno però
lavoriamo perché ci piace io con degli
amici ho fondato a roma uno spazio si
chiama impact abe uno spazio grosso di
coworking san lorenzo dove succedono
cose si incontrano persone molte
d'ispirazione molto carino spesso in
questo spazio
ospitiamo università istituzioni
recentemente abbiamo avuto un gruppo di
manager di manager che sono stati
portati lì dalle aziende per capire in
che direzione va il design la
progettazione e la gestione
il mercato è a questi personaggi allora
gli uomini erano veramente beautiful c'è
anche le donne
quindi l'uomo era alto col gessato il
cravattone
la chiave della bmw la donna minimo
tacco 12 il taglierino la testa active
cioè tutti e due uomini e donne avevano
il coltello giacca cioè metaforicamente
erano arrivati lì perché nella vita
avevano accoltellato nell'ordine i
clienti tutti i giorni i fornitori
un giorno si e un giorno no e i colleghi
perché la struttura tipica dell'azienda
vecchio stile è piramidale vai su solo
sa qualche libri accanto insomma non è
che ci sono ho semplificato un po ma non
troppo ci sono ritrovati a sentire
parlare di cosa dico design di
coinvolgimento dell'utente finale dello
stakeholder all'interno del processo di
pianificazione controllo di apertura di
ascolta lo stagista che ha delle cose da
insegnarti
questi erano cioè c'erano senza parole
senza ossigeno e erano dei t red a cui
gli togli gli togli la carne umana cioè
erano così questi erano letteralmente
sbalorditi erano evidentemente incapaci
e perché cresciuti in un'altra epoca
perché le soluzioni che funzionano oggi
sono quelle che nella storia della
collaborazione dal co design e dal
pensare alle cose per qualcuno con
qualcuno non rifilargli le basta per
fare margini puoi fare il tuo utile ma
si stanno sviluppando dinamiche di
questo tipo e la crisi buffa ancora è
che intorno a loro si muovono i ragazzi
dello spazio di coworking diciamo molti
sottomettere 70 molti colleghi ken stott
bicicletta magari in testa del car
sharing
insomma ero più simili ecco a erano più
simili a questo tipo di animale che si
adatta tutto mangia qualsiasi cosa che
se il caso diventa vegetariane magari a
che legano per sopravvivere soprattutto
brutto bello io l'ho di finire
diversamente bello ecco magari perché
è proprio questa uscire dai canoni della
bellezza no la diversità come valore qui
in segna un teorico richard florida dice
bene che è nella diversità che nasce
l'innovazione se non diamo spazio ai
diversi non ai belli ai diversi non
andiamo da nessuna parte perché i versi
sono diversi sono quelli che ti hanno
capito qualcosa o che hanno capito che
cosa non funziona e da quello che quando
hai capito che qualcosa non funziona
magari era giusti ai diversi piace fare
noi diversi sono quelli che hanno
scoperto il pollice opponibile e dicono
sì ok che magari rischi né o de masi
hanno postulato alla fine del lavoro
loro l'ozio creativo oppure quell'altro
che dice no fine del lavoro perché con i
robot ci sostituiranno e ed è finita poi
scopre di avere questo pollice scopri
che sia stato creato per fare no quindi
noi voi loro ad esempio lui vuole fare
il giardiniere
lei vuole fare la scrittrice non si pone
il problema diciamo le mani faccio e non
è in fondo e sono curiosi e mangerebbero
tutti i giorni il frutto dell'albero
della conoscenza anche perché poi l'idea
di dire non faccia niente tutto il
giorno già sono iperattivi di loro non
faccio niente tutto il giorno cioè in
fondo che palle anche rob paradiso
terrestre presenti esperti e quindi ecco
non so sopportato buono cattive notizie
volevo con voi e condividere su un
cerchio che non si chiude su una cosa
che dobbiamo fare tutti i giorni e che
alternativamente meravigliose brutta per
chiudere voglio solo ringraziare eva per
quello che ha fatto ovviamente perché
insomma io veramente fosse qui insomma
ringrazio e va perché alla fine
io credo sabbia reso liberi ora tocca a
noi andare avanti grazie